I'm on the trail of Andrew Tate the
so-called king of toxic masculinity
who's been arrested by Romanian
authorities over sex trafficking and
rape claims
here in Bucharest like much of the world
he's a divisive figure
I don't like him at all I can say that I
hate him
I don't see why people would hate him he
has the freedom to do whatever he
chooses and pleases
he said some wrong stuff about women but
at the same time I think he guided like
a lot of young boys you know through
depression and struggles and like that
Tate has been outspoken about his views
on women in a video that recently
resurfaced from his banned YouTube
channel he said the women that stayed
with him could not go out they're not
allowed out like all Tates away so they
go out with the friends no no no no you
don't go to the club with your friends
no you stay in the house and this is the
compound that those women would have
been staying in
well this is Andrew Tate's property in
the Bucharest suburb of voluntari and
this is often referred to as a luxury
mansion
but if you look at it from outside well
it looks more like a a warehouse in a
fairly Dusty Tatty Street rather than
something terribly plush get a different
story though when you pair through that
gate over there some some small gaps and
we can see through that and there are
four luxury cars lined up there one of
them are a Rolls-Royce Wraith very
expensive vehicle also see a swimming
pool and statues you can see kickboxing
paraphernalia and the name Tate has been
put up on two of the world we know that
on that side of these walls there is a
very highly appointed very expensively
maintained property so once again we've
got this kind of curious duality of the
luxury and plush side of that life over
here and here this rather drab exterior
but
it was here at the end of December that
Andrew and Tristan Tate along with two
other women were arrested by Romanian
police who say that this property is the
heart of a web of criminal Enterprise
that has involved rape and trafficking
it is of course an allegation that the
Tate Brothers deny after seeing the Tate
Brothers compound are headed to the
courtroom where their hearings are being
held
the Tate's most recent court appearance
happened here in the Bucharest court of
appeal they were in that courtroom
behind me in a hearing held in private
went on for five and a half hours
journalists like me were thrown out of
the room just before the Tate Brothers
arrived and there is huge amount of
interest in their case in Romania in
Britain and of course around the world a
lot of people want to know how this
story ends because if convicted of
people trafficking organized crime rape
the tape Brothers face years and years
in prison
it is a complex tale so to hear what's
next for the Tate Brothers make sure to
follow Sky News on social media as we
stay on the trail